>>Female presenter: Hello everyone.
Welcome and thank you for joining us today.
We're very excited to have Gene Baur of the
Farm Sanctuary here today at Google New York.
Gene currently serves as president and co-founder
of Farm Sanctuary.
From humble beginnings selling veggie dogs
at Grateful Dead concerts to fun animal rescues,
Farm Sanctuary has become the nation's leading
farm animal protection group.
Over the past 25 years, Gene has visited hundreds
of farms and has really become a pioneer in
the field of undercover investigations.
He's also educated millions in the process.
Gene's achievements include winning the first
ever cruelty conviction at a US stockyard,
as well as introducing the first US laws to
prohibit cruel farming confinement methods.
Gene holds a Bachelor's degree in sociology
from California State University, and also
a master's degree in agricultural economics
from Cornell.
In 2008, Gene released a national bestseller,
Farm Sanctuary: Changing Hearts and Minds
About Food and Animals.
We still have a few in the back that are free
you if you'd like to have one.
And he can also stick around to sign autographs.
And on a personal note, I had a chance to
visit the New York Farm Sanctuary last summer,
and was just so impressed to see the work
with the abused and abandoned animals, and
left feeling very inspired.
So please help me in joining-- and welcoming
Gene Baur to the stage.
[applause]
>>Gene Baur: Thank you very much.
[pause] Wow, well, thank you so much, and
thank you for being here and for your interest
in these issues.
Most of us don't think very much about what
happens to animals that are being raised on
farms.
And most of us would be shocked to learn.
So I'll be talking about some of that.
I will also be talking about some of the positive
stories, some of the experiences we've had
over the years.
I'll start with some pictures of the animals
at the Sanctuary.
At Farm Sanctuary, the animals are our friends,
not our food.
We treat them like most people treat their
cats and dogs.
Cows get to be who they are.
They get to go outside.
They get to exercise.
They get to graze.
Pigs get to go out and root in the soil.
Pigs are very earthy animals.
They have very sensitive noses, so they can
smell things under the earth.
But they also have very powerful noses.
Farmers used to put corn around tree stumps,
and the pigs would go there and [chuckles]
root up these old tree stumps.
So their noses are very powerful, but they're
very sensitive.
And when you think about these animals living
in these factory farms where, for 24 hours
a day, all they're doing is breathing in the
noxious fumes of their own waste, it makes
that kind of confinement even that much more
upsetting.
When the animals first come to Farm Sanctuary,
oftentimes they're very frightened.
They've only known cruelty at human hands.
But as time goes, they learn to trust us.
They learn to enjoy life.
They learn to play and experience pleasure
and joy for the first time.
It's a beautiful thing to see.
And they also show companionship and friendship.
That's a picture of Lydia, who we used to
call the Hugging Turkey because you'd go out
into the barnyard and kneel down, and she
would walk over to you and crane her neck
around your neck, like she was giving you
a hug.
So I've spent a lot of time at the farm over
the past 25 years, enjoying the company of
these animals and watching people being touched
and inspired by these animals.
It's a beautiful thing.
But I didn't grow up on a farm.
I actually grew up in Hollywood, California.
I had a cat named Tiger who I totally loved.
And although I loved Tiger and I loved the
other animals I knew, dogs and cats, I was
still eating other animals!
And I didn't really put them together.
But as time went, I started recognizing that
I didn't have to eat animals.
And I realized, as I grew up, I never really
made a conscious choice to eat animals.
It was something everybody around me was doing,
so I just started doing it.
And I think most of us live our lives in a
way where we just do things that other people
around us are doing.
It's just what we do.
We're very social animals.
We learn from those around us.
And so my parents were eating animals, my
brothers and sisters.
Everybody I knew was.
So I did it without really thinking about
it.
But as time went and I started recognizing
that I didn't have to eat animals, and that
these animals had feelings much like cats
and dogs, and that it was healthier, I went
vegan in 1985.
I got a couple slides here talking about the
health impacts.
There's a book called The China Study that
I would recommend for anybody interested in
the science behind the benefits of plant-based
eating.
But this just shows the health care expenditures
per person in the US versus other countries.
They're very high in this country, partly
because of the system, but also largely because
of the way we eat.
Because we're not as healthy as we could be.
And sadly, our health care expenditures continue
increasing.
There's a movie out right now called Forks
Over Knives that I would recommend if you
haven't seen it.
The experts in that movie estimate that we
could save 70-80% on our health care costs
in this country by shifting to a whole foods,
plant-based diet, shifting away from processed
food, shifting away from animal food.
The way we eat has profound impacts, not only
on other animals, but on our own health.
When we eat in a way that we do in this country,
we're seeing huge problems.
Heart disease and cancer are the top two killers.
The risks of both could be seriously lessened
by shifting towards a plant-based diet.
Another impact animal agriculture has is on
the environment.
These are some quotes from a United Nations
study called Livestock's Long Shadow.
And as you see here, it talks about how the
livestock industry is a major contributor
to the most significant environmental problems
we're facing.
It's a major player responsible for contributing
more to greenhouse gas emissions than the
entire transportation industry.
So if you take all of the cars and trains
and boats and planes and combine the emissions,
it would be less than what comes from animal
agriculture.
This is according to the United Nations.
[pause] According to the UN, the livestock
sector should be a major policy focus when
dealing with problems of land degradation,
climate change and air pollution, water shortage
and water pollution, loss of biodiversity.
The contribution is on a massive scale.
The contribution to the solution could be
huge.
Now, unfortunately, agribusiness is very entrenched
in politics.
They've invested for years in the legislative
process.
They have a lot of control.
Back in the 1970s, there was a report that
went out that encouraged Americans to eat
less meat.
Now, that report was in print for about a
day, and then it was changed and reworded
to say, "We should eat more meat that is lower
in saturated fat" which mixes up the message
and has the ultimate result of people eating
more meat.
We've continued doing that, and our health
has suffered as a result.
Another cost of animal agriculture has to
do with energy use.
This is a slide from a New York Times article
that was entitled "Rethinking the Meat Guzzler",
and it compares the amount of fossil fuels
needed for a vegetarian meal versus a meat
meal.
It took 16 times more fossil fuels for the
meat meal.
All these problems have been exacerbated over
the years by this move away from small farms
towards larger industrialized operations.
The number of farms in our country has been
decreasing.
The size of each farm has been increasing.
So we don't have the typical family farm that
many of us envision anymore.
We have these industrialized operations.
[pause]
Now, when Farm Sanctuary started in 1986,
I spent a lot of time going to stockyards
and farms and slaughterhouses to document
what was happening.
This is a picture taken of Lancaster Stockyard,
which was, at the time, the largest stockyard
east of Chicago.
Cows, pigs, sheep, goats would be transported
here to be sold.
There were seen as the pillar of the-- Oops.
[pause]
The animals, when they were being handled
at these stockyards, were often seen just
as commodities.
What became apparent was the way I looked
at these animals, and the way that these livestock
people looked at the animals, was very different.
I would look into the animals' faces.
I would see their expressions.
I would recognize that they were afraid.
The handlers were not looking into the animals'
faces.
They're literally looking at cuts of meat.
They're looking at body conformation.
They're looking at meat on the hoof.
And they sell them by the pound.
So it's a very different perspective.
And when these animals are seen just as commodities,
they're oftentimes whipped, they're beaten,
they're shocked.
Living animals are thrown away.
Animals die routinely in the process.
That's a picture of the dead pile behind the
stockyard.
The day I took this picture, there were dead
pigs, dead cows, dead sheep.
As I approached, the maggots were so thick
you could hear them buzzing.
It was a hot August day.
And the stink was horrible, as you can imagine.
The sheep at the far right was actually alive.
She lifted her head.
And as you can imagine, we were stunned to
find a living animal thrown in this dead pile.
I took her off the dead pile, brought her
to a nearby veterinary, thinking she would
have to be euthanized.
But she stood up.
And she lived with us for more than ten years.
So that's Hilda, our first rescued animal.
Since her, we've rescued thousands.
Each of these animals becomes an ambassador.
When people learn where Hilda came from and
where these animals-- the way these animals
suffer in this industry, it can be a very
transformative experience, especially when
you get to know these animals at Farm Sanctuary
like many people know their cats and dogs,
and hearing about their stories.
So it began a campaign at Lancaster Stockyards
after there was no movement on prosecuting
the stockyard for leaving this downed animal
on the dead pile.
And our position was that if an animal's too
sick to walk, that animal should be humanely
euthanized or should be given proper veterinary
care.
They should not just be left to suffer on
the dead pile.
They shouldn't be left to suffer and die in
the alleyways, which was also commonly happening.
But at the time, Lancaster Stockyards was
seen as a pillar of the community.
It was getting ready to celebrate its 100
year anniversary.
And it was being criticized, now, by this
group of vegans who lived in a school bus
on the tofu farm that funded the organization
by selling vegetarian hot dogs at Grateful
Dead concerts.
So we had a lot of convincing to do in the
community.
But as time went, and as people started seeing
these images of animals left for dead, and
they started hearing about what was happening,
things ultimately shifted.
We were able to get Lancaster Stockyards convicted
of cruelty to animals after seven years of
campaigning.
I went back to the stockyard a few years ago,
took that picture.
It was overgrown, it's now been bulldozed,
it's gone.
We actually had an event there last year at
the Stockyard Inn, which is right next to
the Stockyard.
It was a vegan event to celebrate Hilda's
25th-- the 25th anniversary of Hilda's rescue.
The Stockyard owner said that--.
And he was a little bit worried at first,
having all these vegans come to the Stockyard
Inn.
But he agreed that he would host this event.
And he said that it was a very positive experience,
that he learned a lot about it, that this
is the wave of the future, and from now on,
he's going to have a vegan item on his menu.
And while the stockyard is now gone, Farm
Sanctuary has grown.
That's our farm in Watkins Glen, New York.
You're all invited, in fact, encouraged to
come visit, get to know the animals, experience
that the-- what happens to them when they're
transformed.
And this is our farm in Orland, California.
It's north of Sacramento.
We recently also acquired a farm near Los
Angeles.
All of these are open to visitors, and we
encourage people to come get to know the animals
and look into their eyes and recognize that
they're really not that different than the
cats and dogs who many of us live with.
But far away from Farm Sanctuary, on farms
all over this country, bad has become normal.
Farm animals are genetically manipulated,
artificially bred, mutilated, confined, cruelly
beaten, been killed for food.
Those might sound like harsh words, but it's
very accurate and descriptive.
Farm animals are specifically excluded from
the Federal Animal Welfare Act.
Most people believe and want to believe that
these animals are protected, right?
Well, no, they're not.
They're excluded from the Federal Animal Welfare
Act.
When it comes to state laws, agricultural
practices considered to be common are excluded.
A common practice is one that the industry
has adopted year after year.
So if everybody's starting to put animals
in small cages where they can't turn around,
if everybody is cutting off the tails of animals
without any anesthesia, if everybody is leaving
live animals on piles of dead animals, it's
a common practice, and it's legal in most
states.
And to give you a sense, also, of how powerful
agribusiness is: it's exempt from many labor
and environmental laws.
So this is an industry that treats animals
badly, that harms the environment, that's
producing food that is killing us.
And they're not responsible or not liable
for many of these harms.
I recently heard about how some of the attorneys
that went after the tobacco industry are now
starting to look at the food industry, and
look in a these kinds of issues.
There's a lot of evidence and a lot of information
that needs to be gathered and the case made,
but I think that's a very positive sign.
This is an industry that does a lot of harm.
Most people are unwittingly supporting it
and unwittingly harming themselves.
A big part of our message at Farm Sanctuary
is we encourage people to make choices in
their own lives that are aligned with our
own values and aligned with our own interests.
So instead of--.
When the factory farming issue comes up, instead
of saying, "Don't tell me.
I don't want to know", which a lot of people
do, I think it's sensible to be more responsible
and say, "Look, I want to know, and I want
to feel good about what I'm doing.
I want to live in a way that I can feel good
about, instead of living in this dissonance
and denial."
The other thing is we encourage people to
make food choices that are aligned with our
interests: to eat food that is healthy.
Not to eat food that gives us heart disease
and can ultimately kill us over time and cause
enormous suffering to ourselves and our loved
ones.
That means eating more plant foods in our
country.
More whole foods, less processed foods.
If we make choices that are aligned with our
values and aligned with our interests, we
will see a revolution in this food business.
Most citizens don't think enough about these
issues and are unwittingly supporting this
bad system.
After Lancaster Stockyards was convicted of
cruelty, I traveled around the country documenting
more downed animals.
That's a picture I took in Southern California.
These are downed cows that were being used
for human food, being slaughtered for food.
That's a picture I took in Texas.
This cow was sent to the stockyard with her
calf.
And because cows and calves sell to different
buyers, they were separated.
The mother fought to be with her calf, and
as she did, her neck was broken.
She was left there for hours, possibly for
days.
They refused to euthanize her because as long
as she was still alive, she could be sold
for food.
[pause]
That's a picture I took at a stockyard in
upstate New York.
It was a freezing day.
This calf was sent to the stockyard on the
day he was born.
He was still wet from afterbirth.
And he was dying of hypothermia.
I went up to the stockyard worker and I asked,
"What's going on with this calf?"
And he said, "I have to bury him tomorrow."
So I said, "Well, what if I take him off your
hands?"
He said, "Sure, go ahead, take him."
So I took the calf to a nearby veterinarian.
She tried to take his temperature.
It was so low it wouldn't even read on the
thermometer.
And she said, "What are you wasting your time
for?
This calf has very low chance of survival.
Makes no economic sense.
It's going to cost a lot more than he's worth
to do this."
And I said, "You know, to me, this calf is
not an 'economic unit'.
He's an individual.
I want to do what I can to help him."
And she finally gave him intravenous fluids,
and I took him back to the sanctuary.
I'm happy to say he recovered.
That's a picture of Opie in his prime.
He ended up weighing close to 3000 pounds.
He lived a long life at the farm, lived to
be 18 years old.
And it was a beautiful thing to see his transformation.
You know, as he started healing physically,
that was a good thing.
But he still wasn't really thriving.
When I took him out to the barn to be with
the other cows, and they welcomed him in,
that's when he started thriving.
It really speaks to the fact that these animals,
in addition to having physical needs, have
emotional needs.
And they need to be with their own people.
They need to be in a positive environment.
So just like humans are affected by our social
environment, animals are affected by their
social environment.
In the slaughterhouse or in a factory farm,
where it's about brutality and exploitation
and cruelty, that affects the animals and
it affects the people.
And at the sanctuary, where it's about caring
and nurturing and kindness, that affects the
animals, and it also affects people.
But Opie was born on a dairy farm.
In order for a cow to have milk, she has to
have a calf, just like other mammals.
We don't lactate unless there's a baby to
feed.
That's usually how it works.
Dairy cows today have a calf every year.
The calf is taken away immediately after birth.
The cow is put in these milking parlors where
they're hooked up to machines two to three
times a day, and they're milked intensely.
They'll produce about ten times more milk
than they would in a natural environment.
Their bodies are under intense stress.
I remember reading in an agribusiness journal
a few years back how for a dairy cow--.
With the amount of production they do, and
in addition to giving ten times more milk
than normal, they're pregnant during most
of their lactation period.
So there's this enormous drain on their bodies.
They're in what's called a "state of negative
energy balance."
They cannot eat enough to keep the weight
on their bones, so they're losing weight during
this process.
But I read in an industry journal that for
a dairy cow, it's like running a marathon
every day.
They're pushed very hard.
In a healthy environment, they could live
20 years.
On modern dairy farms, they're sent to slaughter
after just three or four years in production.
[pause] And in many cases, those cows are
so weak, they can't even stand.
They become these downed animals, like that
first picture I showed of the slaughterhouse
in southern California.
Those were all dairy cows who were too sick
even to walk.
They were dragged onto trucks, taken to slaughter
to be used for food.
This picture was actually taken by a dairy
industry veterinarian in California, who was
upset by what he was seeing, took that picture,
sent it to me, and said, "This is wrong.
We've got to do something about it."
We were able to pass legislation in California.
I'm happy to say it is now illegal, federally,
for downed cows to be slaughtered and used
for human food.
Part of that is for humane reasons, but part
of that also is for concerns about mad cow
disease.
The first animal discovered to have mad cow
disease in the US was a downed cow.
The health concerns and the animal welfare
concerns led, ultimately, to a ban on the
slaughter of downed cattle for human food.
That's positive.
But other downed animals, including pigs and
sheep and goats that are too sick to walk,
are still dragged onto trucks and taken to
slaughter and used for food.
It's also interesting to note that the US
Department of Agriculture explicitly allows
animals who are diseased to be used for human
food.
During the process of trying to ban downed
cows in the food supply, we sued the USDA
and we argued that diseased animals should
not be used for food.
Their response to us was that we were incorrect,
that it was legal and common and appropriate
for diseased animals to be used for food.
So whether they're downed or not, diseased
animals are still used for food.
Now, as I mentioned, for a dairy cow to have
milk, she has to have a calf.
The calf is taken away immediately after birth.
The female calves are raised to become milking
cows.
The male calves are useless to the dairy industry,
so the veal industry was actually created
to take advantage of this plentiful supply
of unwanted male calves born on dairy farms.
These calves are chained by the neck in these
crates for their whole lives.
As people have learned what happens to cows
in veal production, veal consumption in the
US has started going down.
It's a very positive step, and it shows that
most people are humane.
Most people don't like to support cruelty.
When people learn about this stuff, they can
take steps to stop supporting it and to eat
in a way that's more aligned with our own
values.
But veal cows are not the only animals that
are confined in these kinds of crates.
That's a picture I took in Missouri.
These are sows that are kept in what are called
"gestation crates."
These are two foot wide metal enclosures where
they live most of their lives.
They're called gestation crates 'cause it's
where they're kept during their gestation
period, or their pregnancy, which lasts four
months.
[pause] They suffer both physically and psychologically.
This one, you can see, has some bruising on
her front leg.
This one is engaging in what's called "bar
biting", it's a stereotypical neurotic coping
behavior that these animals engage in in an
attempt to survive their confinement.
They're basically driven mad.
[pause]
And the third confinement system I'll mention
has to do with chickens that are used in egg
production.
This is a picture of a battery cage operation.
These egg laying hens are lined up in rows,
stacked in tiers, in huge factory warehouses,
that'll hold 100,000 birds.
They're packed so tightly they can't even
stretch their wings.
[pause] They constantly scrape against the
wire bars of their cages.
Their feathers wear off.
They end up with bruises and abrasions on
their bodies.
And they'll live this way for about a year.
After that time, they're sent to slaughter.
But because they're so skinny, and because
they're so beat up, a lot of times the slaughterhouses
don't want them.
So sometimes, they're just killed on the farm.
Sometimes, they're literally ground up alive.
There was a case in California where an egg
factory had 30,000 "spent hens."
That's what they call them after their egg
production cycle when they're no longer profitable.
They're called spent hens.
So he had 30,000 spent hens he had to get
rid of.
He couldn't find a slaughterhouse to take
them.
He got a wood chipper.
He was throwing these live birds into the
wood chipper A neighbor saw this, was upset
about it, called us, called the other authorities.
We tried to get something done about it, and
it was considered to be an acceptable, common
agricultural practice.
So he was not found guilty of cruelty to animals.
And one of the people that came forward to
defend this and say it was okay was a veterinarian
with the American Veterinary Medical Association.
You have these institutions that are looked
upon as experts who have bought into a situation
where bad has become normal.
They start defending practices that most people,
when they think about them, don't feel very
good about.
[pause]
Now, I mentioned that these spent hens are
useless to the meat industry, or are of very
low value to the meat industry.
That's because today, we are raising chickens
in huge numbers for meat.
They are very distinct breed.
They've been genetically bred to grow twice
as big and twice as fast as normal.
The egg laying hens do not grow very big or
very fast.
So when you're at the hatchery --and this
is a picture of a hatchery-- and they're hatching
the egg laying hens, you have both males and
females that hatch.
The females are used for egg production.
The males are useless.
So what happens?
[pause]
That's a picture I took behind a hatchery
in Pennsylvania.
These are the unwanted male chicks that were
thrown away the day they hatched.
What an irony, you know?
The egg, a symbol of spring and birth.
They fight their way out into this world to
be thrown in a trashcan.
[pause]
That is at another hatchery.
These are live chicks thrown in a manure spreader.
Spread on the field, literally like manure.
[pause]
That's a picture I took at an egg factory
in New Jersey.
I was there to document the battery cages.
As I was getting ready to leave, I came across
this trash can full of these birds.
I thought they were all dead.
But as I got closer, a couple of them started
moving.
I took them out of the trashcan and brought
them to Farm Sanctuary.
We tried to prosecute that egg factory for
cruelty to animals.
For leaving live birds in the trashcan.
Their lawyer argued, in court, that they could
legally treat the birds like manure.
And the judge said, "Isn't there a difference
between live birds and manure?"
Their lawyer said, "No, there's not a difference."
They were found not guilty of cruelty to animals.
It just gives you a sense of how bad has become
normal, how weak the law is, and how this
industry gets away with such blatant mistreatment.
It reminds me of a quote from Ruth Harrison,
who wrote Animal Machines.
[pause] So I think that's the situation today,
where we have this system that has become
normalized, institutionalized.
And not only is this the case in the field
and in communities where animals are being
raised for food, but in our society, generally.
We eat in a way that supports this system.
And then we have health problems.
A lot of us know people that are on heart
medication when they get to a certain weight,
age.
That becomes normal.
If they're on heart medication and they're
on heart medication, we all must be faced
for that future.
This is what everybody deals with, right?
Well, my dad had a heart attack about 15 years
ago now.
He went to the hospital, and they were feeding
him bacon and eggs.
[light laughter] It killed me, you know?
[chuckles] My dad then started reading about
this.
He's not a vegan, but he's eating a lot less
animal foods, and that's a-- and his health
has improved significantly.
Then, I'm 50 now, so a few years back, I figured,
"I'm kinda getting old.
I should go to the hospital and see how my
health is."
I went and the doctor was taking all these
notes.
"Any record of heart disease in the family?"
I said, "Yeah, my dad had a heart attack."
And one of the first things he said to me
after that, without taking any tests or anything,
was, "Well, I might want to put you on heart
medication."
Whoa.
And then--.
I didn't go back to that doctor.
I went to somebody else, and I said, "Take
my blood."
They did, and they analyzed it.
And everything was in the normal ranges, except
for one statistic that was outside the normal.
That was my bad cholesterol.
It was below the normal.
So I thought that that was a good thing.
Even in the medical profession, you have doctors
and experts who mean well, but who have, I
think, been acculturated to accept certain
things.
That, "Well, a certain age, most people need
heart medication" is one of these beliefs
and assumptions that we operate by.
I think it's something that needs to be challenged.
[pause]
I had mentioned how we have two distinct breeds
of chickens in this country.
I showed you how the egg laying hens are kept.
This is how the chickens who are raised for
meat are kept.
Just in these massive warehouses.
They grow twice as big, twice as fast as normal.
They grow so fast, their hearts and lungs
have a hard time supporting their bodies.
Every year, millions die of heart attacks
before they go to slaughter at six weeks old.
But it's still profitable because we raise
about nine billion of these chickens every
year.
So the industry can afford to lose hundreds
of millions because they're growing twice
as fast as normal, and it's still profitable.
These birds' overweight condition, where their
hearts and lungs cannot support that sort
of growth, somewhat perversely parallels our
own problems in this country, now, with obesity.
I've got a series of slides here, now, from
the Centers for Disease Control, showing the
rates of obesity in the US.
Starting in 1985 with the darker blue states
there indicating 10-14% of the adult population
obese.
By 1990, we see it spreading.
By '95, we have a new darker blue color indicating
15-19% of the adult population obese.
By 2000, we now have a new color indicating
more-- a higher percentage with obesity.
2006, the last one I have available here,
indicating even more so.
This is a problem that has spread.
It's been recognized, now, as an epidemic
in our country.
It's, I think, the beginning of a process
of change.
I am very happy with what Michelle Obama is
doing.
Talking about eating more fruits and vegetables,
having a White House Organic Garden.
And amazingly, she's been criticized for that.
It's crazy.
Also down in Washington, DC, at the USDA building,
there's actually something called the People's
Garden.
It's a garden.
It's a very important, I think, symbolic gesture
that we need to take control more of our food
choices and eat in a way that we feel good
about, instead of doing what we have done
before, just because we have done it before.
This is really what this boils down to: thinking
about how we're eating, thinking about how
we're living, and asking ourselves how we
feel about it.
Then making choices that we can really feel
good about.
Then eating food that is good for us.
And that does not support an agricultural
system that is destroying the planet like
animal agriculture is today.
[pause]
Now, when we first got the farm in Watkins
Glen, New York, one of our first visitors
was a pig farmer.
He came over to the farm.
I was talking with him in the pig barn.
He looked down and saw these young volunteers,
maybe weighed a hundred pounds each, taking
care of these five hundred pound sows, cleaning
up after them.
This pig farmer was stunned.
He said, "Those animals are dangerous.
They're aggressive.
You'd better get out of that barn or they're
going to attack you."
I told him that we had never had these pigs
attacking us the way he was describing.
He said, "Look, I'm a pig farmer.
I know these animals.
I've raised them for years.
I understand them.
You can't trust them."
To make his point, he talked about how he
had a sow who had piglets.
He took her piglets away, and she came after
him.
He didn't recognize that his action caused
that response.
Sometimes, we become so narrow-minded, and
we start acting in a way and thinking in a
way that is so limited that we don't recognize
how our own behaviors cause certain impacts.
That was the case with this pig farmer.
When the animals do come to Farm Sanctuary,
as I mentioned, oftentimes, they are very
frightened because they've only known cruelty
at human hands.
And so when we go into the barn, they will
be defensive, and they will step back.
But as time goes, they learn to trust us.
They know they're in a safe place.
It becomes a positive experience for them,
and also for us.
When animals are treated badly, we don't want
to see ourselves as mean.
So we then start coming up with rationalizations
and justifications for why we have to do this.
This pig farmer, for instance, said, "Those
are aggressive animals.
You have to put them in the crates, otherwise
they'll attack you, or they'll attack other
animals."
That's a justification based on this assumption,
that these animals are mean.
Another justification that is made is that
these sows are not able to raise their young.
So we have to put them in these crates in
order to protect the babies from the mothers.
They actually believe that they needed to
put them in a-- This is a farrowing crate,
which is where the sows give birth.
They have space to stand up and lay down,
and the piglets can nurse through the bars
when the mother lays down.
The pig industry says they have to do this
to protect the babies, which is so completely
counterintuitive, that a mother pig or a mother
animal of any species can't raise their young?
But this is something they actually believe.
It's kinda ludicrous when you think about
it, but this is what they really believe.
Now, a couple years ago, there were floods
in Iowa.
We sent a team out there to rescue some animals.
Many, sadly, died in their crates and never
got out of these factory farms.
But some did.
One of them was a sow named Nikki, who was
pregnant.
She'd been in the gestation crate.
She got out of the farm.
She got onto a levy to give birth, amidst
all this flooding.
Our people were able to find her and her babies
and bring them to Farm Sanctuary.
When we go into the barn with her, do you
think she attacks us like this pig farmer
was describing?
[pause]
That's her with her babies.
That's her with Susie, our shelter director.
She's not attacking us!
She knows she's in a safe place!
These animals are not that different than
us.
If you've had a positive experience with somebody,
you're going to welcome that.
If you've had a negative experience with somebody,
you're going to be concerned about that.
Walking around Farm Sanctuary, it's a beautiful
thing to see these animals literally smile.
They enjoy life.
[pause]
The people that raise these animals on factory
farms become jaded, become used to certain
things.
These are good people, in many cases, just
doing bad things.
Could you imagine what it would be like working
in a slaughterhouse, where for eight hours
a day, all you're doing is cutting the throats
of animals?
That does something to you.
That's a brutal, bloody existence of violence,
a violent job.
And it's something that I wish nobody had
to do.
Our first campaign to challenge the confinement
of animals in these factory farms was in the
state of Florida back in 2000-2002.
I went to the director of the swine unit at
the University of Florida, where they had
sows kept in crates.
I talked to him about our desire to protect
these animals.
The first thing he said to me is, "What, you
want to put us out of business?"
Again, this is the assumption and the fear
that he had.
I said, "Our goal is to prevent suffering."
And then he started talking to me about all
the reasons why they had to put these sows
in the crates.
The same reasons that this other guy, who
visited our farm, said: "Well, these are aggressive
animals.
You've got to put them in crates to protect
other animals and people.
The sows crush their babies.
You've got to put them in these crates to
protect the babies."
He also said that today, it's impossible to
be a farmer and to do it the old-fashioned
way.
You had to raise animals in these industrialized
operations in order to be profitable.
So these were all the assumptions he described.
And I countered each one, saying that these
animals don't have to be kept that way.
"We have a farm.
The animals don't need those crates."
In terms of the idea that factory farming
is the only way to make a living, now, there's
a burgeoning movement towards small farms,
towards farmers' markets.
The number of farms in the US has just started
going back up.
It's because you have these small farms that
are starting to come into existence.
It's a very positive trend.
I was talking to him about these things, and
his demeanor changed.
He had been combative, but then he became
a little bit more reflective.
He said, "You know what's missing on farms
today?
Pigmanship.
This real understanding of animals.
I've talked to Temple Grandin about this,
too, who is a livestock handling expert, designed
many systems currently in the use in the US.
She says that farmers today, and workers today
on farms, don't understand animals.
That's what this guy keyed in to.
What's missing today is pigmanship.
Then I was getting ready to leave, and the
last thing he said to me was, "You know what
everybody should see?
Is a sow build a nest."
That's one of our guys at our farm with straw
in her mouth, building a nest.
They do this.
These animals build nests.
Sows, in their natural environment, will raise
their young cooperatively.
They will babysit for each other.
They will gather together to fight off predators.
I remember seeing something on the Discovery
Channel a few years ago, where you had these
wild pigs, mothers and their babies, and this
big cat.
It might have been a leopard or some kind
of big cat.
It came in to try to get one of those babies.
And those mothers fought off that cat.
That cat was lucky to get out alive.
At one point, he's on his back.
So these are fierce protectors of their babies.
Which is a natural, motherly thing to do.
But on these factory farms, that is not seen
at all.
It's actually seen as an obstacle, because
these industries want to take these babies
away and fatten them for slaughter.
When we confine animals in this way, and treat
animals and exploit them in these ways, there's
a tendency for us to start rationalizing.
[pause] We put the animals behind bars, and
in some sense, we put ourselves behind bars.
We start thinking things are a certain way.
They don't have to be that way.
[pause] What I think is important, now, is
for us not to just be mindless consumers,
but for us to be citizens and to make mindful
choices that are aligned with our own values
and our own interests.
I think if everybody does that, we're going
to see a huge shift.
There are a few quotes here that I like a
lot.
"Each snowflake in an avalanche pleads 'not
guilty.'"
"Everyone thinks of changing the world, but
no one thinks of changing himself."
And "How wonderful it is that nobody need
wait a single moment before starting to improve
the world."
There's a lot of things in this world that
are outside of our control, that we can't
do very much about.
But when it comes to what we eat, we all have
a lot of control over that.
We can make choices that can make a world
of difference for other animals and for ourselves
and for our planet.
I love this quote from Margaret Mead. [pause
] You know, the number of vegans in the world
is pretty small today.
But it's growing.
And it's actually not a new idea.
Pythagoras was a vegan thousands of years
ago.
Recently, people like Bill Clinton have decided
that eating plants instead of animals makes
sense.
He's concerned about his health problems,
so he became a vegan.
After reading the books by the experts and
the movie I mentioned before called Forks
Over Knives, and his health has improved as
a result, Mike Tyson went vegan recently.
He's no longer eating ears, thankfully.
[laughter] I think, with Mike Tyson, what's
really interesting is that, as a kid, he was
bullied.
Most people don't think about this, but he
was bullied as a kid.
He was younger, and older kids bullied him.
He raised pigeons, and he loved his pigeons.
And then one day, one of these bullies came
in and killed his pigeons.
That's when Mike Tyson became a fighter.
Then he was mentored.
He had good role models.
He worked hard.
He achieved.
And then, something happened.
He started probably hanging out with the wrong
people, started--.
The ego, the money, the power, the greed,
all that kind of stuff started.
Hedonism, of all these kinds of things started
playing in.
Kinda lost his way.
And I think, now, he's trying to regain his
way.
I don't know him, but just hearing his story,
it could be a story of redemption.
You know?
Being in one place and then coming out of
it.
He became vegan.
I think that was part of it for him.
And then there's people like Ellen DeGeneres,
and more and more folks recognizing the benefits
of eating plants instead of animals.
And each person has to make their own choices.
As I say, I've been a vegan since 1985.
But each of us has to decide, for ourselves,
what feels right.
But it's important to actually think about
it, and to be mindful about it, and not to
mindlessly go along, because that's what everybody
else is doing.
Because that approach has led to enormous
problems over human history.
And I don't need to go into all the types
of bad things us humans have done over the
years, but in most cases, there's usually
a rationalization of why we had to do it.
People are very good at coming up with good
reasons to do really bad things.
So it's important to really think about how
we feel when we think about our actions and
the impacts they have on others.
And the thing that makes me so hopeful is
that most people are humane.
Most people are compassionate.
We have empathy.
That's--.
We're hardwired to have empathy.
When you see somebody else hurt, I mean, there's
been science showing this-- it affects us.
And other animals, by the way, have similar
capacities.
When they see others hurt, they feel it.
So that empathy suggests our connection with
others.
When we act in alignment with that, it's good
for the others, for the other animals, and
it's good for us.
To that idea, all the animals at Farm Sanctuary
say, "Thank you for being here."
And I'm happy to take any questions anybody
has now.
So thank you all very much.
[applause]
>>Female #1: Thanks for coming here today.
I thought your talk was super interesting.
Sometimes, I hear from the other side that
it's these industrial practices that make
food affordable, and that our population,
much of the population can't really afford
it unless we grow animals these ways, plants
in weird ways.
What do you think about that?
>>Gene Baur: I think it's an important question.
The goal of farming is to feed our world.
The key question is: what is the best way
to feed our world?
I've spoken at agribusiness conferences about
this specific topic.
My point of view is that, by growing plant
foods instead of animals foods, it's a heck
of a lot more efficient.
To grow animal foods, you need to grow lots
of corn and soybeans.
70-80% of the corn and soybeans, or even more,
grown in this country is fed to farm animals.
If we really want to feed people, we should
be growing food for people, not for animals.
It takes a lot more water, a lot more fossil
fuels, a lot more resources to grow animal
foods.
I was making this case at a group of dairy
farmers once.
They kept coming back to me and saying, "No,
the best way to feed the world is through
industrial animal production."
And I kept saying, "Well, all the evidence
suggests that it's inefficient.
If we really want to feed the world, we should
be eating more plants.
I asked them, "Where were they getting their
information that animal farming was efficient?"
They told me the name of the book.
It was called Saving the Planet with Pesticides
and Plastics.
[laughter] That was really the name of the
book.
So it just speaks to our ability to rationalize
and come up with reasons for practically anything.
But the idea that healthy food needs to be
expensive is another challenge.
I believe that right now, healthy food in
this country is too expensive.
I think one of the reasons for that is because
the demand is so strong, and there's not as
much of a supply as there needs to be.
But there's simple things we can do.
For instance, instead of grabbing a bag of
potato chips, we can eat a sack of potatoes.
You know?
[laughs] But then it's a matter of new habits.
Instead of just getting something, opening,
and eating, there might be some food preparation.
So it's new habits that maybe need to develop.
There's another assumption that is: as people
become wealthier, they want to eat more animal
foods.
That has happened historically.
Is that a good trend?
I don't think so.
[laughs] I think what it speaks to is: with
wealth, tends to come greed, tends to be the
desire to use more stuff.
And I don't think that that's healthy.
I think you have people, now, who have done
very well financially, who are actually deciding
not to eat animal foods.
John Mackey, the CEO of Whole Foods, for example,
is a vegan.
So you have a very strong market for vegan
foods.
There are companies that are selling vegan
foods at a high price because there's a strong
demand.
And I would say the same thing goes for animal
foods that are raised in ways that are not
as bad as the factory farms.
Cage free, free range eggs, things like this.
Those tend to sound a lot better than they
are.
"Free range" only requires animals have access
to the outdoors.
But "access" isn't defined.
So you can literally have animals in a warehouse,
with a small door that goes to a crummy little
paddock.
And that's "access to the outdoors."
That's "free range."
And again, you have such a strong demand,
such strong opposition to factory farming
now, that people are selling products like
that and making them-- making a lot of money
by [pause] exploiting that market, really.
So the food business is evolving.
I think the best way to get food is at farmers'
markets.
The closer we can get to the source of our
food, the better.
The further removed we are, the more chances
there are for us to not really know what we're
getting.
[pause] Yeah.
>>Male #1: I'm just curious: do the animals
ever fight?
I could imagine if you have bulls or something
on-- even in the sanctuary, is that a problem
that you have?
>>Gene Baur: You know, the animals at Farm
Sanctuary do sometimes have issues about who's
supposed to sleep where.
So they will sometimes push against each other.
But they set up their own social system.
They create their own mores and their own
rules.
So they do-- They have very rich emotional
lives and social lives.
So yes, they will sometimes skirmish.
But they usually work out their difficulties
and differences.
[pause] Yeah.
>>Male #2: A question, you were sorta talking
about this a little bit.
What about-- What do you see in the political
side and the subsidies, because I know they
have a lot to do with what you were mentioning.
A lot of the corn and beans being fed to animals.
We know there's a lot of subsidies going to
corn farmers.
So, I mean, are there a couple of things that
you see, from the political standpoint, from
the lobby standpoint, that are big issues?
>>Gene Baur: Yeah.
>>Male #2: And related to that, I guess we're
in election time, so to put you on the spot:
do you see the way the different candidates
or different parties are addressing any of
those?
And if you were voting strictly on that, how
would you go?
>>Gene Baur: Boy, oh boy, oh boy.
[laughs] [laughter] Oh man.
Agribusiness is so entrenched.
Federal monies and supports favor the existing
system, the status quo.
I've worked on legislation for a long time,
will continue doing so.
But we usually can only make modest reforms.
And we will continue working on legislation,
but I'm increasingly coming to believe that
the marketplace is where a lot of the change
is going to happen.
We see more vegan restaurants, more farmers'
markets, community-supported agriculture programs,
community gardens.
The political process is so disheartening,
I'm sorry to say.
It's important to be involved.
It's important to vote.
It's important to let our concerns be known.
But we're up against an industry, when it
comes to animal agriculture, that is so entrenched.
I mean, they don't pay property taxes in certain
areas.
They have preferential access to water.
They can pollute it without having to clean
it up.
Taxpayers clean it up.
And there's not a lot of transparency.
So I wish I could give you a great news that
we've got somebody and they're fighting, but
both parties are pretty well entrenched in
the whole industry thing.
I would just say it's important to let our
concerns be known.
Usually, the lawmakers who tend to support
animal welfare legislation and legislation
that promotes a healthier food system tend
to come from urban areas.
There's some really good things happening
in New York right now, dealing with the soda
pop and, you know.
So there's some positives.
A lot of that, though, may happen at the local
level, which could then eventually filter
up to the national level.
But nationally, you have agriculture committees
that are controlled by lawmakers who represent
agricultural districts.
There was one, in fact, that recently introduced
legislation who tried to nullify state laws
protecting farm animals, because we've been
able to pass some of those over the past ten
years.
So you have these federal legislators that
are so entrenched.
They tend to have a lot of control over the
committees that address these type of policies.
I think a lot's going to happen more locally.
And I can't really comment on who I would
vote for.
[laughs] But you know.
Yeah.
>>Female #2: I have a question for you about
vegetarianism and veganism.
You described a lot of how animals are treated
cruelly and how they are killed.
Now, I'm vegetarian, and I'm trying to understand:
if I'm a vegetarian and don't become a vegan,
is there a way for me to avoid animal cruelty,
or is it just a given that any milk product
that's created is a product of cruelty?
>>Gene Baur: Well, in commercial production,
the animals are seen more as commodities,
production units, than as living creatures.
So on modern dairies, the cows have a calf
every year, the calf is taken away.
In commercial production, I would say that
cruelty is inherent.
Now, it's conceivable that if somebody had
a pet cow, and the cow had a calf, and you
shared the milk, theoretically, that could
work.
But, in a commercial operation, you can't
have that calf there because they're taking
some of the milk.
And also, when a calf nurses, he nurses regu--,
like 12 times a day or so.
So that makes it so the cow actually produces
less milk.
What they do on modern dairies is they suck
'em dry, and then they fill up with milk again,
and they suck 'em dry.
That's the way to maximize production.
Having a calf suckling is going to lessen
the production of the cow.
But theoretically, a person could have cow's
milk, sharing it with the calf.
But a bigger question, too, is: do we need
cow's milk?
[laughs] You know?
We can live without it.
>>Female #2: Does organic farming play a role
at all in this?
>>Gene Baur: Organic falls into that same
category of "sounds better than it is."
A lot of these organic labels sound better
than they are.
And again, you have the calf taken away.
It's an inherent problem.
[pause] That's what I'd say about that.
>>Female #2: Thank you.
>>Gene Baur: Thanks.
Yeah.
>>Female #3: Hi.
First, I just wanted to tell you what an inspiration
you are, because I've followed a lot of organizations,
animal rights organizations over the years,
and yours is, by far, I think one of the few
that actually treats animals as individuals,
which is great.
>>Gene Baur: Ah, thanks.
>>[Female #3]: My question's around messaging
some of this stuff, because being a vegetarian
or a vegan, you tend to get a lot of questions.
And one that I haven't been able to come up
with a good answer to, it's sorta bizarre
if you are thinking of animals as individuals,
but the question is: if everybody goes vegetarian,
where do all the factory farm animals go?
>>Gene Baur: [laughs] Right.
>>Female #3: Do you have any suggestions about
responding?
>>Gene Baur: In our country, we raise nine
billion.
So it's a huge number.
That's more than there are people on the planet.
There's a lot of animals.
But the majority of those are the chickens
that are raised for meat.
They only live about six weeks.
So they're--.
And they're being mass produced.
The reason we have so many is they're being
mass produced.
It's not likely we're going to have a vegan
world overnight.
So the chance of having nine billion animals,
at any one time, is very unlikely.
Plus, we don't have that many alive at any
one time, because they're killed at every
six weeks.
So just do the math on that, there's only
maybe a billion or so, whatever it is, alive
at any one time.
We don't have the nine billion alive at any
one time.
But change happens incrementally.
It's likely that--.
And we are starting to see, in fact, that
as people eat fewer animals--.
And the number of animals being killed for
consumption in the US has stared going down
a couple years ago.
Very positive trend.
The market will respond.
Producers will stop breeding them.
These animals have been mass produced, genetically
bred, artificially inseminated.
So as the people start eating fewer, they're
going to stop producing so many.
A concern, though, I have is that there's
also, potentially, a push for export.
Like with the tobacco industry.
When there was more awareness and people were
saying, "I don't want to smoke cigarettes
in this country," there was a push to export
it.
And that's a concern right now.
There's this push to export these habits.
But I think that, in response, basically,
the industry will respond to the market.
And it is doing so already, in terms of killing
fewer animals.
Now, the export issue is an aside, but the
market is going to, I think, ultimately, push
the industry in a better direction.
And it's starting to happen.
Yeah.
>>Male #3: First, thanks for coming.
>>Gene Baur: Oh, yeah.
>>Male #3: I went to the sanctuary, and I
really enjoyed it.
>>Gene Baur: Oh, great.
>>Male #3: I took my daughter.
>>Gene Baur: Great.
>>Male #3: A question that I have is: there
are many organizations that take care of animals,
but I never saw on TV a good commercial that
actually explained what we have to say.
Is there a reason for this?
>>Gene Baur: [sighs] Well, one of the reasons
that we don't have television commercials
with our message out far and wide is it costs
so much.
We've worked on campaigns to ban certain cruel
practices.
We've done this to the initiative process,
where we get commercials on television for
about a three week period of time.
And it will cost millions of dollars.
But it's a very focused effort.
[pause] Meanwhile, McDonalds and the dairy
industry and all fast food businesses are
pushing their message over and over again.
We're just not able to compete financially.
So we need to figure out how to get our message
out far and wide, inexpensively and efficiently.
I think that's where a place like Google [laughs]
or the internet is an enormous new tool.
And that's another thing that gives me great
hope for change, because with education and
awareness comes change.
But we're just not able to afford it, is the
simple answer to that question why we don't
have these commercials all over the place.
Sure.
All right.
Well, any other questions?
[pause] Cool.
Well, thank you all so much.
I'm happy to answer any more questions if
you have them, and sign books.
Thank you all very much for coming today.
[applause]